but do you think there's a lot less
psyops and there's just a lot more again
incompetency mistakes human error
confusion chaos but how do you
accidentally swear under oath that
aliens exist well I don't think he did
he actually say that he just kind of in
the context of the conversation you can
make two conclusions he's lying to us or
he's saying aliens exist
the way maybe the way he phrase it I
lean towards lying to us
but it's either that or he's literally
he's he's there's no honest way he's
claiming a dog was found in a satellite
you know our mold was found in in a
module that was in space he was asked
about non-human pilots and says yes
we've recovered them
hmm
how do you accidentally lie about that I
don't think I don't know no no you you
either intentionally love oh yeah maybe
he thought he was telling the truth like
babazar I think he really thought he was
telling the truth because they brought
him into a room with nine drones and
they they put a puppet of a green alien
and one of them in the seat and he
remembers seeing that and then they
probably had some wild meta material
that was vibrating so fast you couldn't
physically touch it because it was
creating force and he was like oh
because he remembers that part of it I
believe that's something about it
um and then he just got his hand on a
window yeah and then they get him to go
tell everyone that it was and then they
tell him it was saved from Zeta reticuli
they feed him some nonsense so that if
he ever does go public he'll feed the
public some nonsense yeah
and so this guy could be similar or he
could have been just blind think about
how they compartmentalize the Manhattan
Project nobody knew what they were
working on right so you bring these guys
in and you're you're building some kind
of technology and let's say it's not
even anti-grav or force field or alien
attack or whatever let's just say it's a
meta material that's um lightweight and
very very dense like you know very
useful
[Music]
you don't want this guy whose job is to
file paperwork to know how you make it
in the event he leaks things so what do
you say aliens here's a question what
would aliens think of us if they showed
up on Earth I don't know what do we
think of cows chickens well I don't know
if that's even the question because I
you know bringing it back to
children and how we treat children
there's estimates that we kill about 50
million pre-born children globally
tens of millions of reborn children
what would they think about that yeah
when you talk about that you have to you
have to acknowledge that the people that
are actually having abortions they don't
conceptualize it as killing they just
don't like you I know I know that that
you do a lot of people that are
listening to
um people that are pro people that are
pro-choice don't consider it killing
that's why they can do that's people who
get abortions and people who approach
Choice are two different things fair
enough okay people that are pro-choice
do not consider it generally and this is
a generalization but people that are
pro-choice don't consider it killing at
all they consider it a medical procedure
and that's why they want to make control
the argument the way they do I think
that's pro-abortion people I think the
traditional pro-choice like I said that
oh normally does many of them do think
it is killing but the point that I'm
making is the people that find
pro-abortion uh because most people
aren't Pro like Pro abortion and fine
fair enough but I don't know most of the
left is pro-abortion but most people
most people I think there's a variety
there's a lot of different reasons and
there's a lot of different beliefs
around it about whether or not I'm
actually killing someone is it a someone
am I just going to put my head in the
sand but the back to the aliens question
the fact is we are killing as a society
globally I don't I don't know how tens
of millions of people and hey look uh we
got too many chickens in chicken city so
we gotta stop having more of them uh
they sometimes make more of themselves
mostly we incubate so now we're probably
gonna give some away or something like
that or just move them to new locations
but we have too many
so so they'd see us as the lower life
form is what you're saying no not
necessarily I mean they would just be
like I don't I think it would be a
neutral question they'd say
it is it is they're they're calling
they're self-calling you know what I
mean the same as they call any other
species they call themselves and humans
are I think a lot about the brutal the
barbarism of humans like the this in
order to survive we have to kill we have
to destroy another animal or another
plant steal its energy yeah we have to
consume destroy and consume the thing
actually kill things to consume them and
like how horrific for an alien if an
alien just subsisted off of light and
that was how they got their energy they
would look at us like the most horrific
evil creatures but if they also consumed
and destroyed to live they probably look
at us as equals and be very concerned
that there would be a war so like I
don't know if I if I Came Upon a species
that just annihilated everything in its
path to survive I'd think of it as a
disease
uh I I think not the humans do
everything in their path that's
hyperbole but the fact that we have to
kill to survive so there's a big
difference between killing a chicken you
know to eat the egg to eat the chicken
then killing a human being
I mean right there's there it is very
likely that their technology I would say
it's the likelihood is 100 that there
exist technologies that we do not have
access to Simply by the nature of the
chemical composition of our planet
it's possible that if aliens exist they
came to exist on a planet that had more
oxygen or less nitrogen or something
like that resulting in a different path
towards technology they come to this
earth and they're like whoa this is very
very weird the aliens could be
squid-like they could be giant balls of
gas they could or you know like a thin
membrane or something and we exist the
way we are based on the chemical
composition of the planet salt water
there there is a an interesting argument
that alien life will be nearly identical
to humans
in that the evolution of the eye based
on what we think we know independently
occurred in a bunch of different species
for the same reasons light sensitivity
of cells and then there was a higher
rate of success with a certain shape of
certain cells and and you know
eventually the eye forms I watch this
really amazing documentary on it
it may be the case
that if we do encounter aliens they will
be very very very human-like they will
breathe a similar uh atmosphere why the
oxygen level of our atmosphere is
perfect for fire which you can use to
separate elements and at the basis level
we make Metals but eventually we've got
to the point where we're synthesized
also cooking food and stuff yeah yeah
cooking food more efficient production
but look at Dolphins this is the
argument that I find compelling as well
that that the forms might be like human
yeah the forms that that have inhabited
Earth are the likely forms that life
tends to make considering the conditions
in the universe no no but not tends to
make but would succeed in terms of
technological advancement thumbs all
possible thumbs very very smart they say
big brains but they will never smelt
because they're underwater and they
can't some Dolphins I'm listening to
this show right now they're like you son
of a like I wish I had hands I'd
show him but you can't sorry can't do it
and whales either big brain super smart
they can probably perceive things we
can't they definitely can with sounds
and all that but they're not going to
start a fire so that's all they'll ever
be but we are in this auction Rich
environment oxygen actually destroys
cells oxidization and we've evolved to
be able to exist here and we make fire
and then we throw stuff in it and then
that stuff melts and we separate things
and then we we extract chemicals and
hormones and now we have computers and
Rockets synthesizing synthesizing fuels
and all that stuff
my big concern is if aliens do exist and
they show up and they don't just
immediately kill us I don't think that
will happen but if they did show up we
would not do a good job or we would
really struggle Humanity at large right
now with how to treat them in an ethical
way because I think our bioethics
generally speaking today especially in
the Western World especially in America
are very broken and you look at
reproductive Technologies as an example
and cloning right and the ability to
clone and the question of you know can
you create a clone of yourself and then
take their organs can you what do you
how do you treat a cloned embryo you
know how do you treat embryos that are
being used for research there's all of
these ethical questions that we're not
getting right do you think we're
practicing the wrong thing we're killing
killing human beings you think clones
have souls absolutely if they're human
an individual human absolutely like a
different soul from you or like if
someone cloned you be like a different
soul well I mean identical twins have
different Souls but they're biologically
identical I just tweeted out a video of
a nano machine taking a firm and
impregnate in an egg with it and the
sperm's just like laying there I'm like
how many we have so many lazy people
already we don't need to take the lazy
sperm and make new lazy it's crazy
um but how do you think Lila like how do
we solve for this bioethical problem
where we're killing young people because
it's like a resource struggle I feel
like if people don't without the
resources we can't support the young
we've always had to leave the weak and
suffering behind in the tribal life and
things like that because you can't
support it
um and it does terrify me that they're
impregnating eggs with weak sperm but
like how do you well it's funny with the
resource thing just to touch that for a
second we are we have more resources
than we've ever had in arguably human
history and we have the technology to
have more more people and support more
people as a planet than in the human
history and all the all the predictions
about oh the universe is you know the
world can't handle more humans you know
the malthusian ideology of we can't
we're gonna have to kill people off
because we can't feed the world that's
not come true because as human beings
have grown and pop the Earth our
Technologies has have our Mastery of the
world has but anyways separate from that
though I think the big question is
what's the correct way we treat each
other you know do humans have human
rights and if we have human rights what
are they and I think most people I don't
know your guys's position but I think
many people today would say yes we have
human rights even the United Nations
says there's human rights and so the
question isn't whether or not we have
human rights it's where is the line what
is a human right right exactly but I
think most people would agree that the
right to not be killed is a fundamental
human right because if you don't have
that you can't have any other rights
right and that is the pro-life case in a
nutshell if you're a human you have
human rights and the first human right
is not to be killed similarly our
Declaration of Independence you're
endowed by we're endowed by our creator
so we're created they're not given to us
by each other we get them from on high
we are endowed with these inalienable
rights and the first of them is life
liberty The Pursuit of Happiness right
so life comes first and all humans have
that right whether you're born or
pre-born it doesn't matter you're a
human you have that right I don't
believe there is a way that you can ever
really win this battle
and the reason is these aliens
pro-abortion individuals are desperately
trying to remove themselves from the
gene pool but you are desperately trying
to save them
this conflict will result in more and
more leftist ideologies pro-abortion
ideologies emerging in our current
system this means that they can vote and
they will vote for policies that allow
them to terminate themselves in the gene
pool
ultimately then they will reduce the
pro-life element conservatives will just
have more influence and more children
but then they will stop abortions that
once they have the authorities like
abortions done which means the remaining
pro-abortion people will have more and
more kids and those kids will hold the
idology of pro-abortion until they get
too too many then they'll vote for
abortion and call themselves again
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time